[Music]
Rachael Lindsey's Bachelorette
contestants revealed I think they just
really want to take the time to find the
right group of guys for me and I can't
complain about that they are a part of
the most successful most diverse and of
course the most dramatic cast that we
have ever had on the show
Chris Harrison announced the cast during
a Facebook live on Wednesday their jobs
quirky as ever
Jonathan 31 years old Jonathan's a
tickle monster
then there's Lucas okay he's 30 years
old and he's a he he is or his
occupation is wah boom it's a lifestyle
ken he's 35 he's a professional wrestler
he also probably cries more than anybody
this season there's also guys who have
history with Rachel
here's spread his camp counselor was
Rachel yeah 20 years later fred is
trying to live out his grade school
crush and you can guarantee these guys
are gonna bring the drama mario smooth
maybe too smooth maybe just maybe he's
not here for the right reasons watch for
Lee this season he's gonna be more of an
instigator et has been with Rachel every
step of the way here's what she's
looking for in a husband oh my gosh um I
need a funny guy I need you to be able
to talk sports and then I need a guy who
knows exactly what it is that he want
all right I'm sure you've already got
some opinions tweet me who you think has
what it takes and let me know which guys
you're already skeptical of I'm at her
name is Deidre
[Music]
you